when you talk about parenting there's
lots about your mother in this book and
sometimes i think family members
they don't like being part of the act
your mother
loves it yeah like she loves it like
properly loves it
and she also feels that there's a
certain amount of status that's come
with
with with her level of celebrity one of
the things she loves doing
is she gets nervous when she's at a shop
that they might not recognize her
and so regardless of what she's buying
she will always sort of pay with her
card
and make sure they see the surname just
sort of go yes that is ranganath and
correct
and she says she feels like she's won
the lottery or something but
one of the things i keep having to say
to her she's just overthinking it she
she wrote off her car at the just at the
beginning of lockdown and then
she couldn't get any all the car places
are closed down and she's trying to get
replacement she was she's a key worker
she works for royal mail so she was
trying to figure out a way to get to
work and i said to just take micah i've
got a mini you can just borrow that for
as long as you want
and um and so she borrowed the car and
then it got to the point where we were
talking about getting another car and i
said so what do you want to get
and she said you know the problem is
ramesh is not as easy as just buying a
car
because i'm a celebrity's mother and and
with that becomes a certain amount of
expectation i don't want people to think
oh why is shanti driving this
i said what can i say what mom i said
why don't you why don't you just keep
the minute you see
you know just have it it's fine i don't
mind and she said i darling i don't
think
i don't think i should be seen driving a
minute i said mum
the celebrity that you're a mother of
drives the minute
how could it how could it not be good
enough for you
yeah she just properly loves it she just
really does get
nervous about about bringing across that
status you know